طائره اوكرانيا البصيره
اسند اليها دور الوصول لقلب العاصمه روسيه
موسكو او على الاقل كانت سلاح الاكثر
ترجيحا ما هي هذه الطائرات بدون طيار وهل
تستطيع فعلا الوصول الى موسكو وما وراءها
كما يجادل العسكريون اوكرانيون اذا
مسيرات2 اعتمدها الجيش الاوكراني عام 2020
لكنها لم تدخل الخدمه على ما يبدو قبل عام
2022 هذه المسيرات التي يتم انتاجها في
اوكرانيا يبلغ مدى حوالي 800 كم هي متعدده
المهام بما في ذلك الهجوم والاستطلاع
وعمليات البحث وحتى الانقاذ تعمل ليلا
نهارا وفي جميع الظروف الجويه وحتى سيئه
منها يمكنها الطيران لسبع ساعات متواصله
على ارتفاع سته كيلومترات اما سرعتها
فتتراوح ما بين 160 كيلومترا في الساعه
فهي مسيرات قادره على استيعاب حموله
زينتها 20 كلغ من الذخائر وبينها قنابل
جويه غير موجهه من عيار 82 ملم تمتلك نظام
تيار الي يتيح لها بالتحليق بدون حتى
اشاره جي بي اس هذه المسيرات نشطت في سماء
موسكو مؤخرا واقتربت منها في مناسبات عده
بين هجوم على مدينه كولومنا في ضواحي
العاصمه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات